So, I think we've had this before,
but tonight
is going to be the beginning or the
first of a monthly
thing that we're going to be doing. So,
it's kind of a u
family oriented dinner inshallah
slash get together. So, that's going to
be tonight after
and this will be every
month and the last Friday night of
every month, right? So, the last Friday
night of every month, we'll have a
community potluck
and so, you know, it's a good thing
to bring the family out, too.
A lot of times people are not working on
Saturdays. So you know you could take
the family out and bring them here to
mix and mingle and so forth. So again
that is tonight inshallah.
[Silence]
yesterday we spoke about the first
obligation or pillar of wudoo which
was washing the face to include
to include the mouth and nose. The
second is
and notice how washing the face to
include the mouth and nose we counted
those as one. We counted those as one
just as it is counted as one in the
Quran because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commands washing the face and the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
explained it as to include the mouth and
nose. So that really is just one thing.
The second is
to wash the hands and arms
to include the elbows.
Now notice how or remember that
we mentioned that Woo has six
obligations
and that one of those obligations
is
that these things be washed in order
that it be performed in order.
What order are we speaking about? The
order that is mentioned in the Quran,
face, then hands and arms, then head,
then feet. This is the order.
If a person were to change that order in
any way,
the woo would not be valid.
And so remember that when we say that is
the order
just because we washed our hands at the
beginning
which is something the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam did often he'd
wash his hands at the beginning then
he'd wash his face.
We still haven't washed our hands
in order
to include the arms and elbows or the
forearms.
So washing the hands before washing the
face
that doesn't count towards washing the
hands, forearms to include the elbows.
So when we say we begin with washing the
face to include the mouth and nose. Then
we wash the hands,
forearms to include the elbows. We begin
from the tips of the fingers or the the
hands and arms need to be washed. The
area that needs to be covered is from
the tips of the fingers all the way to
above and to include the elbows. All of
this needs to be washed and they need to
be washed after the face, mouth and
nose.
After the face, mouth and nose.
So when we began with washing our hands,
that is a sunnah to prep our hands to
perform wudoo. That doesn't count
towards the washing of the hands and
forearms to include the elbows. Now I
want you to imagine how the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam would have
performed woo.
He didn't have a faucet and running
water and showers.
Usually he would be brought
an open top
almost a vase if you could
imagine a pot.
Okay. Usually they were made out of
pottery clay baked clay. So it they have
different types. Some were wide mouth,
some were closed mouth. Right. Usually
he would be brought
almost a bucket, but it is shaped
a a pot and it's wide in the mouth.
Wide enough to put your hand into it.
And so when he would begin, he would
pour the water into his hand
and wash his hands three times. Then he
would begin to take water out. So he
wouldn't put his hand into the water.
He'd first wash his hands. Then he would
start to put his hands into the water.
And when he would wash his face, he
would put both hands this, wash his
face. When he would wash his hands and
arms, he would put one hand in, cup the
water, and then he would let it roll
down his arm and he would move the water
around with his other hand. This is how
he would perform this. And then the
left hand, he would cup it and let it
roll down the arm. Okay.
Now, does this have to be in that
direction?
This is an interesting question because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
for
[Silence]
mid. foret.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
So it doesn't have to be in that
direction.
If a person were to
wash his hands or his arms under a
faucet and the washing start here and
end here, is that correct? Sure.
Is it correct to start here and end
here? Sure. The prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam would wash his hands and
he would start here and end here
more or less because of the way that
the water would be introduced into this
process more than anything.
It doesn't mean that it has to start
here and end here. It does mean that all
of this needs to be washed to include
the elbows. Now in
Abdullah who is one of the prophet Sam's
servants.
He says that
[Silence]
And so he says that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam would pour
the water onto his elbows
onto his elbows
and really this this joint here this
area this is the milak right why because
when you're washing it this you
might not get everything so he would for
extra measure pour the water on his
elbows to ensure that it is to include
the elbows because the real translation
of the verse is if you wish to stand for
prayer then first wash your faces and
your hands and forearms to include the
elbows that's the translation and your
hands and forearms to include the elbows
the hand in the Arabic language aliad
it starts
at the the hand and ends at the
shoulder. All this this entire
extremity this entire organ is called
or this entire appendage is called
in the Arabic language.
Right?
However,
what does mean in the Quran's language?
This is an important point. In the
Arabic language, all of this is alet.
But in the Quran's terminology, if we
were to gather every place in the Quran
that makes mention of the word yet,
what does it mean? This is al in the
Arabic language.
To the wrist, in the Quran,
to the wrist.
And this is why the addition is made
because unless otherwise specified in
the Quran when the word yet is used,
this is what's meant
just the to the wrist. And so this is
why that addition became critical which
is and wash your hands and forearms to
include the
the elbows.
Right? So this is the exception.
However, in the Quran, this is what is
meant by
one last thing. One of the things that
he would do when he would make udul is
that if his hands were particularly dry
on occasions, he would scrub his
the knuckles, right? He would just run
his hand across. Also,
he would run his fingers between
the fingers of his other hand. Right?
This isn't at every single woo, but this
is something that he would do as well.
Nothing else is part of that except for
one last point and that is the issue of
nail polish.
Nail polish which we'll discuss tomorrow
inshallah.
[Silence]
How you doing, man?
It's busy these days, huh? It's sad. I'm
And I to speak and I'm happy with
my YouTube.